I've got one more surprise for everyone
my wife baked a batch of her famous
gooey gooey butter balls for the office
take one and just kind of pass it around
you are gonna get messy because these
are no joke job enough
your wife's gooey gooey butter ball was
gonna wait to do after the meeting you
I'm so sorry mister so sorry but don't
worry everyone they're even gooier when
you wait and back to Christian know what
it was about to say was I bought bein a
it was a ten billion dollar deal the
media said was impossible Congress said
it was illegal but through sheer force
of will I made it happen
okay then John go ahead and pass out
your wife's little treats yes sir these
are extremely gooey
you